you know i think of myself as an
optimist because
i believe it's self-evident that human
progress
is real that humans use their
innovative capacities to
exteriorize their ideas and make
manifest what they imagine they then
design and they then create what it
means to be
human is functionally that we are a
tool-making animal and we create tools
in the world that allow us to overcome
boundaries right the whole
concept of
scarcity is contextual and technology
becomes then a resource liberating
mechanism now these days everyone's
talking about the blockchain and how the
blockchain is going to be a
revolutionary platform to unleash
new
modes of collaboration and cooperation
that are defined principally by the fact
that
the blockchain allows for decentralized
cooperation and collaboration for a
decentralized form of exchange
and trade in order for economics to work
in order for trade to work in order for
any exchange and collaboration to work
we need to manage uncertainty because
where there is uncertainty there cannot
be trade if i am offering you this and
you are offering me that but i don't
know if that's what you're really
offering well then that collapses the
whole equation and similarly like if you
don't know what you're getting from me
so
managing uncertainty
is a
prerequisite
for trade and economics and the exchange
of goods and services and for any
collaboration and cooperation to
transpire the system relies on managing
uncertainty and typically we rely on
centralized institutions to do this for
us whether it's the authority of the
church or the authority of the
government or the authority of the bank
or the authority of the entity there's
always an intermediary a centralized
intermediary that helps to manage this
uncertainty between people but what
makes the blockchain seemingly
revolutionary is that it is an immutable
registry that is fully decentralized and
unhackable
and so it
creates a platform and it creates
a
instantiation by which
uncertainty can be managed without
centralized control and so it becomes a
peer to peer world where collaboration
and cooperation can be massively and
radically decentralized truly
peer-to-peer no centralized control no
entity of control and yet the system is
still trustless and immutable and
unhackable it still manages uncertainty
and so everybody has to agree within the
blockchain what's what and who has what
and so methods of exchange are accounted
for units of exchange units of value are
accounted for it's a platform that
unleashes the possibility for the first
time of massive and radical
decentralization while still managing
uncertainty which allows potentially for
a revolution in creativity value
creation value exchange trade
collaboration just a new kind of
economics freed from the shackles of
centralized control which up until now
was a necessary evil right because
centralized control is subject to
corruption and you need checks and
balances on the very methods of
centralized control that we used before
to govern economics and trade and
development between humans but now
potentially if deployed in the right way
and it is still early stages the block
chain and its nascent world of
cryptocurrencies and mania can can
potentially uh be this game-changing
revolution that again hits its
immutability and its unfalsifiability
and its unhackability really just allows
us to account
for uncertainty manage uncertainty just
potentiate the next sort of
game-changing step in human development
and our capacity to collaborate at scale
in a decentralized fashion with minimal
constraints and minimal constrictions
and so it
in a way it's a kind of triumph for
human entrepreneurship
and human enterprise and i'm hopeful
that will lead to
modes of collaborative spontaneousness
right just spontaneous collaboration
that will lead us you know to a place
beyond petty conflict
and beyond having the stressors of
managing uncertainty and instead just be
free
to create
so that's the best case scenario of
blockchain technology and let's see you
know let's see if we can
steer these tools in the right direction
and free the brave reckless gods within
us all
you